excuse me sir do you know where I can
find a fidget spinner
I am a mother maniac
I'm constantly tapping fidgeting I saw
this thing that was trending online
fidget spinners and apparently it helps
people who have anxiety and ADHD I
figure if there's a tool out there that
could be helpful for that let's go check
it out
we found one place in LA that had a
fidget spinner left everywhere else was
sold out walmart sold out you can order
them on Amazon I don't have time for
that [ __ ] we are here at the original
farmers market in Los Angeles about to
pick up a fidget spinner oh my god
there's goats are these for sale Oh
fidget spinners let's go found the toy
store here at Kip's toy land
let's see what they have hello oh hi I'm
Ben really nice to meet you
tell us a little bit about the shop here
so we're the oldest toy store in LA
we've been here since 1945 my grandpa
started it who's a prisoner of war when
he was captured his dream was to open a
toy shop so we've been here ever since
it's a pretty amazing store it gives me
a old-school vibe but it's like what a
toy store should be how often would you
say people come in asking for fidget
spinners probably 25 times a day I've
never seen anything so as quickly as the
fidgets spinner or the demand from
people of every single age this is my
first time ever seeing a fidget spinner
so here it is you hold it like this and
I'm not very good at it but you flick it
and then it's spin give it a whirl
there you go it's a satisfying feeling
for sure likes licking a pen or like
twirling a pen or I'm a compulsive
fidgeter for sure well then there's your
fidget spinner alright I'll take it
okay I'm not very good at it well thank
you so much you guys scream Oh Julian
check it out let's get out of here and
wring this back in the office yeah
pretty good it's so satisfying really
think I understand why people love these
things now I'm gonna focus on directing
it just takes your mind like to a very
calm place you should get one for your
stressed-out girlfriend I should I don't
understand ours would help people but
the more I do this the more I like it
but I would do with this if I were kid
I'd spin it and knock my friend in the
head with it I feel like I can use it
once and not least again this is a
terrible find that this is enjoyable
people mm sub-team is it a fan it's not
a fan I feel like I have to pay a lot of
attention to the choice you know like I
don't think I could do work why do this
oh he's really cool okay it looks really
stupid when you were doing it but it was
cool
yes I always got to talk to kids or
they're banning this in a lot of schools
right now because too many kids are
getting distracted but man screw schools
they will ban anything this is fun like
what is the harm in this at least
they're not doing drugs
guys oh pardon this Pinter option but
I've got a new toy to show you oh is
this gizmo a spin on this let's for this
all day can I use that weapon do you
think they should be banned from schools
named from schools yeah you could throw
this in someone you didn't see scaring
into this it's just a distraction when I
was in school I used to do all over the
paper all the time and some teachers I
got mad at me and some teachers that got
it and we're like oh yeah he's paying
attention he just like needs to be
drawing too and this is like the perfect
representation so the question of the
day started with what the hell is a
pigeon spinner figured it out I feel
like while I'm using this the ATD part
of my brain is distracted on the spinner
and it lets the rest of my brain focus
on whatever I'm supposed
not hurting anyone else so I'm all about
it I don't think it should be banned in
schools I think that parents and
teachers should give this a try who
knows it might help them too I've
officially become addicted I called this
one rude off the pink nose reindeer
spinning is my destiny I called this
around the rolling back around the world
whoa
then it's gonna have to go back oh
thanks ebony you're just getting worse
and worse for the world come on
[Music]
Wow
[Music]